great to see you Jarrett collector mania
you've been in so many great shows and
films over the years let's start off
with Game of Thrones what was it like
becoming a fan warg
I had to get really method for that role
I spent a lot of time eating human
beings barbecuing mostly a little bit of
you know oregano and some curry spices
you know they taste great a good buy
with some curry spices
no please don't believe a word I'm
saying I'm really blessed to be part of
Game of Thrones it was such a fun role
to play and you know when I was asked to
send in the tape by my manager for the
role I got incredibly excited and when I
found out I was in the show like oh my
god I mean game was thrown that's
ridiculous
so yeah fantastic time shooting that in
Iceland and in Northern Ireland and just
feel really blessed to be part of that
tell me a little bit about that bird of
prey that you have when we first see you
and tell me about the makeup as well
because very striking the way the fans
luck isn't it yeah I mean the makeup is
incredibly exciting the makeup artists
on Game of Thrones are amazing they
basically work out of a trailer and I
mean we were on a location whether it be
in Iceland or Belfast and we're miles
away from the actual studio so they're
doing these incredible makeups basically
in the back of a trailer and there ain't
no how they do it they make us all look
so scary and so incredible and one of
the most exciting things about this role
was being able to work with the owl and
as since I felt I love animals I love
most actors are scared of working with
children and animals I love it if a role
it requires working with kids or with
animals I'm more likely to do the role
because I just adore animals and
children but I said to Dan and Dave when
I met them at Comic Con along to you
know last year before I even started
working on the show that I'm really
excited about meeting out and everything
was really built up that I would meet
the owl but unfortunately our little
furry creature couldn't make it to
Iceland for the first batch of shooting
because he couldn't get his passport in
order so I had
work with a little stuffed friend he was
great but then we got to Ireland and I
was even more excited thought maybe this
time I'll get to work with the owl and
they scheduled a day for me but it was
such a busy shooting schedule that I
never actually got to meet the owl and I
was really upset I was like I want to
meet the owl it just never happened so I
get to vicariously meet the owl through
watching the show because I know he was
there on my shoulder in theory and that
warms my heart moments we enjoyed most
watching the show back the moments I
enjoy most of the ones that haven't
aired yet the best stuff is yet to come
with the thins and the wildlings and I
won't say too much about what happens
but let's just say it gets messy real
fast so so how much you looking forward
to seeing that I'm incredibly excited
because obviously I was there for the
shooting and it was in quick it was very
very tough shooting it was all location
shooting at night all the rain and the
mud is route that you're going to see is
real and it was very very hard work but
incredibly fun and challenging so I'm
incredibly excited to see the work and I
got to work with some amazing people I
mean kit harington's amazing I loved
working with kit Rose Leslie Christoph
have you who placed home on such a
fantastic group of people to work with
so blessed and so I'm I'm I'm as excited
as anyone else to actually see what it's
finally going to look like the final cut
you know I wish they would because we
don't get to see it beforehand they
don't show us you know so I'm going to
be watching it live with everybody else
I cannot wait I'm really excited
we've seen along the way through the
four seasons and this season some crazy
deaths in Game of Thrones over way which
do you think has been the best death so
far in season four
I have to say I don't know if it was the
best death but definitely the most
satisfying was seeing Joffrey get it I
mean come on
Jack Gleeson is one of the loveliest
loveliest people you whatever you've
heard this a million times but he plays
literally one of the most hated people
on camera and watching him die was
beautiful just beautiful but I think the
best deaths so far in season four was to
fight in the tavern that to me that
scene I watch that scene several times
over I just kept rewinding it and keep
pepperi watching it and I'll see I've
met museum and and Rory and their two
hilariously lovely people and to see
them playing those roles the way they do
in doing that scene and it was just
delicious to watch but Derek there are
going to be some great deaths coming up
which I cannot mention we cannot wait
now if you had to meet your maker on the
show how would you like to die I want to
be killed by a dragon that that's the
only way to real I mean the best way to
die in this show is to be burnt alive by
dragon let's face it I mean come on
Ivan killed many great ways in all of
the work that I've done but I think to
be killed by dragon I'm still waiting
yeah
that that would be my favorite you also
work with Rose Leslie on Game of Thrones
he plays Ygritte she said watch I love
her to death she's one of the sweetest
people ever and I have some behind sites
put behind the scenes footage of her
which I will never release publicly but
every time I watch it Rose it absolutely
puts a smile on my face that footage of
you practicing shooting the bow and
arrow and Castle black just is some of
the most hilarious stuff ever
but she's adorable I love Rose what is
it about character that people have
taken to you so much I have no idea
probably because
at the time I know when I wash it as an
audience member as a viewer it's like
what are you doing why are you shooting
him you love him I mean obviously
there's a conflict in the character and
she's first and foremost a wildling and
he's you know Night's Watch and he's the
enemy but she's in love with him and
there's all like conflict but still love
always comes first
you don't shoot the person you love you
know when I was sitting there watching I
was like what are you doing when he is
like a woman scorned never never never
so yeah I think that's why it's you know
and also the great thing about rose she
sounds nothing like that in real life
she speaks very proper you know she has
a beautiful voice and a beautiful like
not posh she speaks very well and so she
puts on this or this northern accent and
it's hilarious to listen to her it's
just like it's great I love it you know
nothing Jon Snow she's really nailed it
you really know that as well and finally
as a fan of the show of course we've got
so many great characters ones I think
about this season have been Tywin and
Joffrey what have been your standout
moments for Tywin and Joffrey in the
various seasons we've had so far a game
of Thrones um god it's difficult there
have been so many I think just about
every time they come on screen I think I
think when Joffrey kills Ross that to me
was just that was evil that was pretty
bad but I think he's he's probably his
best moment though between the two of
them was actually at his wedding you
know I mean that little banter between
him and Peter Dinklage right before he
he gets poisoned is quite literally some
of the best stuff I've seen I love it to
death
but my favorite Peter Dinklage stuff is
is with Charles dance
there's a particular scene where he's
speaking to - Charles hands and having
the scene and and and he's telling him
that I wish it you had never been born
you know you you're the only reason
you're alive is because you share my
name and that's about it you know it it
was one of the most horrific things I've
ever seen on screen that father son and
some of the best acting I think I've
seen period anywhere and I will always
quote that as being I think my favorite
scene in all four seasons period so far
who would you like to in the end see on
the Iron Throne and if you could swap
roles with any other character in the
show who would you like to play I think
I'm closest if I had to play any
character it'd be Peter Dinklage's
character because personally I like that
that's a character I'm closest to for
many many reasons
you know the misunderstood person who
because of the way they look has been
judged in a certain way and that's what
I had I can identify with the most or
possibly the Hound again very similar
kind of character but from a different
side of the fence you know very
misunderstood character they're very
straightforward I mean when he speaks I
mean he says to seaward more times in
one episode than I think I have in my
whole life but we'd all like to do that
wouldn't we I mean just there's a
certain straightforwardness about the
Hound that I just cracks me up every
time he opens his mouth but I think yeah
if I had to play either any characters
in the show it would either be at SAAP
with Peter or with Rory and he would you
like on that throne I think Maisie
should be on the throne well it's been
lovely to speak to Joe thanks very much
you